All right, kid.
Hang on.
You ready for an adventure?
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie.
This is the way.
This will be my Mandalorian Season
3 Episode 6 Trailer.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references.
I know there's a bunch of questions, too.
After episode five,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
Curveball for spoilers.
If you haven't seen episode
five yet either,
but there's some new footage of Mando
and Grogu
going to what seems like a Droid's
only bar, which is meant to be a big joke
on a new hope
like no droid served here in the cantina.
Hey, we don't serve their of what?
You're a droid.
They'll have to wait outside.
We don't want them here.
But there's a ton of Easter eggs
around the room, like zooming and hands
all over the place.
Pretty much
all these droids are meant to be deep
cut Easter eggs for some of the movies
or the previous series.
There's a bunch of battle droids
from Phantom Menace
and the Clone Wars behind them.
In the far back, there's
another super deep cut for a new hope.
This is actually season three.
He was actually a secretary business
communications droid, kind of like
another type of protocol droid
that had a twin CS unit.
CS one that was in
the job was Sand Crawler deactivated.
They got into a crash in the desert
and got separated.
That's
how one wound up in the Java sand crawler.
This other one actually wound up in Mos
Eisley walking past.
Luke Skywalker and Obi-Wan Kenobi.
When they arrived at the spaceport
to go to the cantina.
He was also played by Anthony Daniels,
who normally plays
Threepio in all the movies.
I don't know who the white one is right
next to them.
He looks brand new,
so he might have been introduced
relatively recently in part to the
Disneyland theme park or somewhere else.
Very new.
Right next to them all shiny
looking is the R-7 protocol droid.
Also from a New Hope,
who is affectionately nicknamed the Death
Star Droid because, as you can guess,
his model was used on the Death Star.
They also featured this type of R.A.
seven Droid a bunch of times
in the Clone Wars and Star Wars Rebels.
Right next to him
is the exact same type of droid
we just saw working for Greef Karga.
His design is based on the original Ralph
McQuarrie concept art for C-3PO.
He just a different color.
I believe he's also meant to be
another type of, ah, RFQ protocol droid
who is used a bunch during Star Wars
rebels on Luthor.
They were also called Luthor
Protocol droids because Luthor was Ezra
Bridges, Home Planet Love.
The series took place there.
Speaking of Star Wars rebels in the Ahsoka
series, we just got live Action's
Dave Filoni in a bunch of the directors
from season one.
Also cameo too, because they played
the New Republic pilots in season
one, along with Zeb, Ahsoka, Sabine Wren.
Most of the characters from Rebels,
like the main characters,
will be on the Ahsoka series,
including Thrawn himself.
That's why you're starting to see
so many characters from Star Wars.
Rebels
show up in live action on The Mandalorian
because they kind of use
that as a trial run, as sort of a teaser
for the Ahsoka episodes,
which are coming later this year.
We'll probably get some kind of Ahsoka
cameo scene before the end of the series.
Dave Filoni helped write three episodes,
including this one where Zeb Cameoed
so he tends to write on episodes where
they use characters that he originated.
Most of the time
when he helps write an episode, it's
because he helped originate a character
that they're using in that episode.
So like every single time
Ahsoka has appeared in The Mandalorian,
the Book of Boba Fett.
Dave Filoni has helped write on
those episodes or directed them himself.
Zoom in, Enhancing the front.
There are two R2 units,
and then on the far right,
his head is cut off a little bit in frame,
but he looks just like Rex,
the Droid from Star Tours,
who is also featured during
the book of Boba Fett, is a repurposed
gambling droid, just manning
one of the tables, the one in the back.
Right.
Bartending
looks like a newer model version of 99.
I think this was
just meant to be a callback reference
to earlier seasons of The Mandalorian
in the most Eisley Cantina on tattooing,
where the original model EB 99
Droid was being the bartender.
There's also a couple other droids here
on the left and on the right in up front
that are just out of frame.
We'll probably see
when we get a much wider shot of the room.
But just in general, all the droids in
this room are meant to be super deep cuts
and like I said,
a big callback to the whole joke.
The droids were not allowed
in the most likely cantina.
Like we don't serve their kind here,
but now we're in a bar
that seems like it's droids only.
We don't serve flesh bags here.
If you think you spotted any other droids
in the footage in the trailer,
just write up below in the comments.
But like I said,
there will be more out of frame
that we don't see in the actual trailer.
The major other new footage is either
a Mandalorian flashbacks
to Mandalore itself before the purge
because the dome and the grass here
looks really nice,
or because of what just happened
at the end of episode five with the armor
tasking bo-katan with the mission
of uniting
all Mandalorian clans around the Galaxy.
This could be a scene in present day
on another planet where another clean
a mandalorians
have been living in a dome structure
similar to the ones used like the Sundari
dome on Mandalore.
Because the ship in this footage
is Bo-Katan ship,
but she's had the ship since the Clone
Wars, so it could be said in the past.
You can let me know in the comments
if you think this is her
in the middle of her mission
in present day visiting other mandalorians
or is it meant to be a flashback
to actual mandalore before the Purge?
We've seen Mandalorian flashbacks
in previous seasons, like we saw Mando
flashbacks to his childhood.
I think eventually we'll see
some flashbacks for Bo-Katan.
Speaking of Bo-Katan history,
I know a lot of people now are wondering
if the armor is secretly related to her.
I've talked about this in previous
episode videos
because the whole idea is that we know
duchesses is her older sister.
Like much older sister.
Bo-Katan was actually only meant
to be about a teenager,
maybe a little bit older teenager
during the Clone Wars.
She looks much older than she actually is.
That's why she's so close to Mando's age
and present day.
But their nephew was quirky, meaning
there had to be another sibling
that we didn't know about.
There could be another mystery
sister out there,
so the armor could have been Bo-Katan
mystery sister
that they believed to be dead.
Because just listening to them,
it doesn't sound like Bo-Katan recognizes
the Armor's voice
and doesn't know who she is.
But the armor definitely knew who Bo-Katan
was before she took her helmet off.
I talked about this in my Episode
five video,
but the actress who plays the armor,
Emily Swallow, said that
we're not going to find out everything
about the Armor's backstory this season.
They're going to save
a lot of those details for future seasons,
But she's not meant to be sinister
or trying to stab anyone in the back
or seek power for herself.
She's not trying to steal the darksaber
or anything like that.
She's just trying to help
Bo-Katan and Mando
become the fullest versions of themselves.
According to what they believe to be true.
Mandalorians like she is trying to help
lead them through the way to become true.
Mandalorians all their people reunite
because of this side.
The mythos or so she's
sort of like the Obi-Wan Kenobi in this
situation, shepherding them along the way.
Like this is the way
I do not think
that she is secretly duchess
the team, though
I think that she's still dead
because there's only three episodes left
right now.
I think we will see more of Bo-Katan
actually
going around,
rallying more mandalorians to her cause.
But I think they're saving the coming
together of all mandalorians
like their giant rally moment
till the finale when they all meet
on mandalore and wind up seeing the myth.
Or a lot of theories about this too,
because the whole idea is that to unite
all mandalorians you need
the Darksaber is critical
to leading their people,
even the armor who just tasked Bo-Katan
with bringing them all together
on Mandalore went on
and on about the importance of the myth.
Azor previously had told Mando
how critical the Darksaber
was to mandalorian culture,
and whoever leads them has to wield it.
So will there be a twist with the finale,
with all these mandalorians kind
of forming a truce and coming together
under a unified banner?
I don't think
Bo-Katan is going to try and kill Mando
and take it or anything like that,
but I don't think that they're going
to always see eye to eye either.
All the time.
They've had a couple of really cool
team-up moments so far,
but the only way
she be able to get it from him
outright would be beating him
in one on one honorable combat.
But since the armor went on and on about
how Bo-Katan was someone
who had lived in both worlds,
I think Roku is also meant to be
an example that a character
who's lived in two different worlds
the world of the Jedi,
in the world of Mandalorians, and
I think they also want to pay off Mando
writing the mythos, or because they teased
that back in season one, like you're
a Mandalorian, your people rode
the mythos or who are Mandalorian?
Your ancestors
rode the great members. Sure,
sure.
You can ride this.
Yeah. Oh, in so he shall eventually.
I think it's also possible
that Bo-Katan and Mando
will lead the Mandalorians together,
because I don't think it's as simple
as one person leading all of them
doing everything by themselves.
Like grogu.
You meant to be a nexus
of the Mandalorian culture in the Jedi.
He's essentially the next star Vizsla,
the next Mandalorian Jedi
into our Vizsla
is the person who created the Darksaber
in the first place,
like this whole symbol of their culture.
It broke.
Those tiny little hands
were just a little bit bigger.
I'd say he'd be the one
to wield the darksaber and unite them all,
but he's way too little right now,
so I think he's just going to be a symbol
of the union of the force
in the mandalorians in them all coming
together,
these two very different cultures
forming a union, also very important.
Grogu
Who is the only one right now that we know
of who can communicate
with the myth of sword through the force.
So they need him for that anyway.
So don't be surprised
if their little family of three
that's forming this season winds up
leading all mandalorians together
like space dad with mom in their child.
Grogu you and the Darksaber
all riding amid the saw now know
there's still tons of questions
about the teaser
for Moff Gideon
at the end of episode five.
Is there an evil group of mandalorians
out there that broken out
because of the best or alloy
or is the best score
alloy just from his dark troopers?
Because remember, in season one
they tease that the Empire had stolen
a ton of the Mandalorians Beskar
Moff Gideon sounds like he used
part of that to create the Dark troopers
to give them super strong armor.
But here's the thing.
Carson Tava found fragments of Beskar
embedded in the bulkhead here.
Normal beskar wouldn't break like this.
It looks kind of like the dark troopers
armor because their armor was Beskar
alloy and Carson
Thibeault actually called that out.
I'm finding traces of Beskar alloy.
Pure Beskar Steel, as we saw,
is highly resistant to lightsabers.
That's why Luke Skywalker
was able to slice through the Dark Trooper
so easily because it was just beskar
alloy, like a less pure version of Beskar.
So I do also like the theory
that Moff Gideon also left
behind that fragment of Beskar
to throw people off his scent
and make him think that the Mandalorians
broke him out.
So The New Republic will be worried
about the mandalorians
in not thinking about him.
They'll be too distracted.
Which lines up with what Carson tava
warned Colonel Tuttle about.
Because I'm hearing moff
Gideon never made it to trial.
There's something dangerous
happening out there.
All these events.
It's not a coincidence.
There's something weird
going on in the outer rim.
You're not going to realize
what's going on until it's too late
if you don't start paying attention now,
that's meant to be a big teaser for Moff.
Gideon and Grant.
Both Ron's forces
eventually rallying in the outer rim,
which is also why Elliott Cain wanted them
to stay away from Navarro,
Why she was trying to get Colonel
Tuttle to not send any aid there.
We don't want the New Republic snooping
around in that part of the galaxy.
I've also seen a lot of theories, too,
about Moff Gideon challenging either
Bo-Katan or Mando in one on one combat
for the Darksaber
and trying to win some of the mandalorians
through his cause
that way, the same way that Darth Maul
did it during the Clone Wars.
Even if it was not a group of mandalorians
that did break moff gideon out.
There are bad groups.
The Mandalorian out there
like the Mauldaloreans,
The Mandalorian Super Commandos.
We could wind up seeing versions of them
in future seasons, if not this season.
Part of the idea with Bo-Katan
going around uniting all mandalorians
is that there will be some groups
who just really, really
do not like the other groups.
The mandalorians like none of them all
get along very well.
I've got a couple other bonus videos
that I'm working on this week,
but my full episode
video will post next Wednesday
after they released it,
so be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
Everyone click here
for my Mandalorian Season three Episode
five Video and click here for all my other
Mandalorian Episode videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe.
And this is the way.